سي إن إن لديها توقعات كبيرة للإعلان
وهي أن
جو بايدن سيفوز بولاية أريزونا ، إنه
الفائز بـ
11 صوتًا انتخابيًا في
ولاية أريزونا.
إلى 49.1
، فاز جو بايدن مرة أخرى بولاية
أريزونا ، دعنا نحضر الآن
كبير المحللين السياسيين في CNN ، يجب أن أقول
مارك بريستون ، حتى أنني كدت اتصلت
بك كبير محللي الانتخابات ، لقد
اتصلت بي للتو بمحلل انتخابات قديم ،
ماذا عن هذه العلامة
هنا نحن أعني  أنت تعلم أنه
بعد أكثر من أسبوع على
الانتخابات وهنا لدينا أه جو بايدن فاز
أه أريزونا ، فمع كل هذا الذي
يحدث
في الولايات الأخرى ، إعادة فرز
الأصوات وتعرف الدعاوى القضائية أو ما لديك جو
بايدن  حصل على فوز انتخابي آخر
يضعه في القمة حتى لو كانت
هناك بعض الولايات المتنازع
عليها والنتائج تنقلب إلى حد ما بشكل صحيح غير محتمل ،
لذا دعنا نتراجع خطوة إلى الوراء
ونتحدث عن سبب ذلك
بورتانت جو بايدن حتى قبل بضع دقائق
فقط حصل على 279 صوتًا انتخابيًا ، ولديه الآن
290 صوتًا انتخابيًا
، ولم يكن يحتاج سوى 270 صوتًا للفوز بالفجر ، لكن هذا
مهم في ولاية أريزونا
في وقت بدأ فيه الديمقراطيون
يفقدون القليل من الدعم
فازوا بولاية أريزونا من بين الناخبين من أصل إسباني ، والآن
فاز الديمقراطيون بولاية أريزونا
مرة واحدة فقط منذ عام 1952 وكان ذلك بيل
كلينتون مرة أخرى في عام
1996. ودعنا لا ننسى أن
أريزونا هي المنزل
أو كانت موطن أه حقًا والد
من التيار المحافظ الذي نعرفه الآن
باري غولد ووتر الذي كان
المرشح الرئاسي الجمهوري للرئاسة عام 1964 لذا
فهذا فوز كبير للديمقراطيين لا
ديموغرافيًا أه وبالتأكيد يضيف فقط
إلى أه مكانة جو بايدن كرئيس
منتخب وعندما تفكر  حول استمع إلى جون
ماكين
وإرثه وكيف أن جون ماكين لم يكن حقًا
من المعجبين بهذا الرئيس ،
أم أن هذا الرئيس رأى حقًا جون
ماكين الراحل العظيم جون ماكين يجب علينا
السناتور جون ماكين
كشوكة في جانبه خاصة
أه بتصويته
بالرفض أه الرئيس يريد التخلص
من
قانون الرعاية الميسورة والآن لديك ولاية
أريزونا كما قلت إن الديمقراطيين
لم ينتصروا
منذ الخمسينيات من القرن الماضي ، أليس كذلك؟  نتخيل أن
له علاقة
بإرث جون ماكين وأرملته سيندي
ماكين
أوم تدعم حقًا جو بايدن ، نعم
يجب أن نعرف أيضًا أن مارك كيلي
رائد فضاء ناسا قد
فاز في مجلس الشيوخ الديمقراطي بالديموقراطية في
مقعد مجلس الشيوخ هناك كان هذا السباق  يُدعى آه
كما تعلمون قبل أيام قليلة ، لذا
مرة أخرى يظهر لنا الديمقراطيون الآن
أن التركيبة السكانية المتغيرة في ولايات
مثل أريزونا ،
تكساس نراها في جورجيا
الآن حيث يقوم الديمقراطيون بغزوات
حيث لم يلعبوا حقًا لفترة طويلة جدًا
أو في كل الفجر